[Musique]
chergé vigneault les gens de son pays
enchanté pour sa fête et les gens
d'ailleurs dans le monde aussi j'ai
vignon a reçu une vague d'amour ça c'est
un cadeau extraordinaire c'est un cadeau
que je n'ai pas à apporter a déposées
quelque part à dire qu'est ce que je
vais faire avec ça je sais tout ce que
je dois faire avec sa réputation
l'interaction avec son public a toujours
imprégné les mots de gilles vigneault
je vais être obligé de tenir pendant les
chansons que je vais faire l'avenir du
fait que je voulais rencontrer et à 90
ans et toujours cette même communion qui
l'animent et qui lui donne le désir de
durer
ce qui a à faire avec ça chers amis
c'est une autre chanson et d'autres
preuves pour sa fête
gilles vigneault s'est offert un recueil
de poèmes le chemin montant est un
nouvel album ma jeunesse
[Musique]
l'artiste prolifique au parcours
exceptionnel vient de finir une tournée
d'automne
bonne fête des vignerons j'en ai rêvé
tout vous en parler merci beau tout le
monde ici à ce monde hayat radio canada
montréal